played with his team they only averaged
two more shots as you see Durant get the
easy dunk right there but they placed so
much more fluid because when steps on
the court he plays with the faster pace
tinder that's leadership and I know he
was a leader because at the end of the
game they put him on the best player
dunk on the whole team like your Golden
State fan you're hoping that did that
for the battery is the rents back as
well finally and hit free for Kevin
Durant that English nicely to keep on
the fall notice off the bench he's hit
four for Durant
Dicky's the lamp it's a beautiful boat
I'm on a motor no I'm not I'm over here
sweating ones at his best yes we did not
know he was guarding that place able to
whip by sea active off the dribble and
Durant with 40 for the night
who's following the ramp
closest player I was going
here's the ramp 10 seconds goes to the
[Applause]
klay Thompson three-point fuel rolled
klay Thompson
elbow jumper can they get 16 of the
warriors 30 this dribbles into a three
and buries another one five in the game
already
that's my late opsin again make it sex
itself
people are out like they are dream on
cycling around play tops
[Applause]
kostik
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kongo fans again treated clay wanted
that three holiday was aware of it play
toys on the mid-range he pulled up and
he had to squirt up you don't think
sales come out to the get sporty and I
think he's got forty okay but he also
has 11 threes Jim he's five of eight
he's got thirteen claims got another one
he got his rhythm back well he's one
away from the record fenced ramana
Damien catching two three they're not
he's taught step Stephan curry just came
over and looked at us and said thirteen
yeah shot clock at four I think they're
looking for him to get fifty shots well
there's forty nine might be really
appropriate
for NBA history
[Applause]
[Music]
the steps if you think you can even
shoot it drive and kick has worked for
Washington in the early going we're
getting good looks step timesheets
Rep goal for ricochet
step two sketches shoot
[Applause]
step again
[Music]
does he fear to get yes
[Applause]
now Steph has 11 points in the last
minute
[Applause]
let's go Bertini Washington say anybody
the courage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it looks like playing against high
school kids for him right now
did that collegiate teams I've ever seen
very have not scored this quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
he's taking one shot which he made so
he's got two points and as you say he's
not concerned about that
[Applause]
[Music]
Fiesta Gary
thirty four point play
[Applause]
not moving for them they Aventis
degraded
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]